as sometimes happens usually about once
every two or three months we had
a very unfortunate last-minute guest
cancellation
today and so in order to not delay the
publication of the show instead of
hearing from one guest i'm going to hear
from a few of you by opening up the
phone lines at 617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
617 area code
caller from 617 what's your name where
are you calling from
caller from 617 i can hear you opening
or closing some kind of cabinet you are
on
live right now
all right bye-bye to 617 that was the
opportunity and it was a wasted one
that's very unfortunate
let's go next to our caller from the 512
area code who's calling today from 512.
uh hello yeah who's this uh this is
andrew
andrew what's going on um so i just
wanted to know like
like what are you what what do you think
of some of these like
republican uh and conservative like
political
commentators like uh ben shapiro
what do i think of them generally yeah
i mean i i disagree with their politics
and i don't really watch them
uh but is i mean i don't know if there's
something maybe more specific you wanted
me to say
um do you think like so like
i have some friends that are uh like
republican
and they watch their videos and will
debate like
you know certain topics or whatever
and i just feel like uh
some of the things that they're saying
could be dangerous
oh absolutely absolutely yeah no listen
i mean i
i guess i should to be more full it's
not just that i disagree with them
i do think that particularly because
they have
very um uh sort of
manipulatable followers i do think that
some of the ideas that are perpetuated
i can't say specifically ben shapiro or
one or the other because i don't really
watch enough of these shows
to be able to say who's doing it and
who's not but much like
mike pence's rnc speech was very
dangerous
in how even it was getting republicans
to question
whether we can it's like almost like
russia where they're both trying to get
us to question whether we can safely and
accurately do an election
uh many of the ideas espoused on these
right-wing shows are dangerous
some of them we know have actually moved
people to
real world violence and they're i'm not
suggesting that
these shows be illegal i'm not
suggesting censorship
what would be great is if we had a
smarter more educated population that
didn't fall for this stuff in the first
place
okay thank you all right for uh
having me on the show and uh keep up the
good work
thanks andrew i appreciate that very
nice to hear from you